ça vous plaît quand vous cliquez sur ce
type de vidéos là trois histoires
d'horreur vous connaissez la recette et
il y en a eu pas mal en fait pendant les
confinements les couvre feu bah oui les
gens creepy continue à être creepy en
plus
déjà petite recommandation d'ubs de rage
sais pas si j'ai déjà fait en vidéo
hérédité incroyable j'ai adoré emile
somare fait par le même réalisateur
c'est lui son deuxième film un autre
délire j'ai un peu moins aimé mais les
deux films sont excellents ils n'étaient
pas voilà pour ceux qui aiment le délire
film d'horreur et où il ya un peu que ça
à foot en ce moment mater des séries et
des films
régalez-vous bon des histoires on en lit
avec lorraine à chaque fois avant que je
la raconte je pense pas que des
histoires qu'ils fassent plus peur
objectivement que d'autres je pense que
c'est juste un truc de sensibilité il ya
certaines mécaniques vont faire made et
les uns et pas les autres et d'autres
mécaniques vice versa c'est un truc très
subjectif l'horreur mais en tout cas ça
continue à me passionner les sûretés
plus de films d'horreur la hollywood
j'ai besoin de frissonner voyage nouveau
conjurés qui arrive j'ai hâte j'ai très
hâte bref passons à nos trois histoires
du jour on commence avec celle de
quentin ya une chose à savoir dans
l'histoire de quentin c'est que là où il
vit dans son pays tout ce qui est
naturel donc les plages les vallées les
forêts bat a le droit d'aller y camper
alors ça vous paraît peut-être évident
mais par exemple en france on n'a pas le
droit d'aller camper où on veut il ya
des airs de campements prévu à cet effet
et si tu va camper ailleurs que là sans
autorisation bas étaient dans
l'illégalité
bref par conséquent quand il était petit
avec sa famille il adorait aller faire
beaucoup de campings
il partait plusieurs fois par an avec
ses parents des amis de ses parents et
donc les enfants des amis de ses parents
ça faisait une sorte de colonie de
vacances cool et la plupart du temps ils
allaient camper sur une plage ce que
j'ai jamais fait perso j'ai toujours été
en forêt avec les moustiques et la peur
des sangliers est campée sur cette plage
il n'était jamais seule il y avait même
des bateaux en fait qu'ils étaient
postés tout le long de la plage avec des
gens qui passaient la journée sur leur
bateau puis le soir il dort mais je sais
pas comment on appelle ça met du coup
c'est plus du camping bref l'endroit où
vous aller camper c'est un truc qui est
très familial tout le monde vient avec
ses enfants passer du bon temps
l'histoire que quand on nous raconte se
passe au printemps 2011
il spécifie qui s'en souvient parce que
quelques mois avant ils ont adopté un
chien un refuge un chien qui s'appelle
parmesan ils expliquent qu'ils ont
adopté ce chien quand il avait six mois
après qu'il ait été exfiltré d'un
business de combats de chiens c'est bon
il le décrit comme un chien hyper à
l'aise avec la plupart des humains et
aussi avec la plupart des autres chiens
printemps 2011
il décide d'aller faire un fameux
camping à l'endroit habituel mais cette
fois il en porte pour la première fois
avec eux leur nouveau chien
malheureusement cette fois là ils sont
partis plus tard qu'habituellement et
donc en arrivant sur place c'est le
coucher du soleil ou plutôt la tombée de
la nuit
alors évidemment établir un camp quand
il fait nuit s'est
un chien est compliqué quant à elle sa
famille comptait sur la lumière des
bateaux et des campements aux alentours
pour y voir clair eux
sauf que malheureusement cette fois là
il n'y a pas d'autres campeurs sur la
plage ils sont seuls ça effraie pas du
tout les parents de quentin qui
commencent à sortir les bagages de la
voiture qui commence à monter la tente
en s'éclairant avec les lampes torches
disponible dans la bonne ambiance comme
il fait nuit et qui viennent d'avoir
parmesan quentin il n'a pas envie de le
laisser se balader librement sur la
plage parce qu'il a de grandes chances
qu'il le perde de vue et qui le perdent
tout court donc ils décident pour le
moment de laisser enfermer dans la
voiture cette plage elle est en forme
d'arc de cercle et tout au long de cet
arc de cercle se trouve une route et une
voiture fait le tour de cette route qui
longe la plage rien d'alarmant
probablement une autre famille qui vient
de monter le camp ici vu que c'est un
spot très fréquemment utilisé parce
qu'il est très beau mais quelques
minutes plus tard la voiture refait le
tour sans s'arrêter
mais le père de quentin s'en fout et
continue à monter le camp quelques
minutes plus tard la voiture revient
sauf que cette fois elle s'arrête le
long de la route et elle s'arrête juste
à côté de la voiture de la famille de
quentin et le conducteur sort de la
voiture
la maman de quentin pense d'abord que
c'est probablement un mec chargé de la
sécurité de l'endroit et qui vient leur
demander ce qu'ils font là et qui
s'assure que c'est une famille normale
qui vient camper faire des trucs normaux
à cet endroit et puis en observant la
silhouette dans l'obscurité qui se
rapproche d'eux il remarque que cette
silhouette elle marche pas correctement
cette personne elle marche comme
marcherait quelqu'un qui est ivre ou qui
est drogué quentin et ses parents sont
intrigués son père temps donc ça
longtemps jeu vers la silhouette pour
mieux voir et c'est là qu'ils
s'aperçoivent que la silhouette en plus
de marchés bizarrement elle a dans sa
main gauche un couteau immédiatement le
père de quentin tend son bras et met
toute sa famille derrière lui et dans
son autre main il tend un maillet de
camping son père très calme demande
d'abord à l'homme de ne pas s'approcher
mais l'inconnue continue après quelques
secondes le père de compte 1 perd
patience et se met à crier sur l'inconnu
elle a connu lui se met à crier sur perd
deux cantons
en retour ce qui est très peu rassurant
quentin et sa soeur ce matin pleurer ils
sont hiller paire cris sur un inconnu
qui lui crie dessus aussi tout laisse à
penser qu'ils vont se battre et que vu
ce que les deux hommes ont dans leurs
mains il y en a un qui va finir dans un
sale état
l'inconnue n'est plus qu'à deux mètres
du père de quentin et laon un chien
arrive en courant sur l'inconnu et lui
mord au niveau du bras de toutes ses
forces
ce cher vous l'aurez deviné c'est
parmesan surpris l'inconnu laisse tomber
son couteau et ils courent jusqu'à sa
voiture parmesan lui ne pourchasse par
l'inconnu il reste positionné proche de
sa famille immédiatement quand un essai
par en rassembleur affaires et retombe
dans la voiture une fois dans la voiture
quand on est réaliste que si parmesan a
pu leur venir en aide c'est parce qu'ils
avaient légèrement laissé ouvert la
fenêtre côté passager pour qu'il ait un
peu d'air et que parmesan à
avoir entendu deux hommes se crier
dessus a appuyé sur la vitre avec ses
pattes ce qui a agrandi le trou et il a
donc pu partir de la voiture et les
sauver c'est bon la famille est donc de
nouveau dans la voiture ils prennent la
direction de leur maison ils veulent
rentrer ils sont choqués de ce qui va
leur arriver
sauf que le réservoir d'essence est
presque vide en arrivant en ville il
trouve une station ici rendent le père
de quand on s'approche de la ville pour
essayer de voir les horaires d'ouverture
et c'est là qu'il entend une voix lui
dire c'est fermé et cette voix c'est
celle de l'inconnu au couteau il est là
assis sur le capot de sa voiture en
train de penser son bras qui saigne à
cause des blessures infligées par
parmesan évidemment quand le père de
quand on voit ça et remonte dans la
voiture et y trace et traces mais il a
toujours pas pu faire le plein d'essence
et lui reste apparemment de quoi faire
50 km ils prennent la route et après
quelques minutes il voit des phares dans
leur rétroviseur et ses phares ils
viennent de la voiture de l'homme
il a compris que la famille manqué
d'essence et il les suit et il va les
suivre sur 40 km il va changer direction
à seulement cinq kilomètres de la
station essence que visait le père de
quentin la famille est soulagée elle
fait le plein en vitesse et après un
long trajet de plusieurs heures à être
parano et à surveiller les rétroviseurs
constamment elle est enfin de retour à
la maison est pas près d'aller camper de
villiers alors on a envie de camper ou
pas bref petites rencontres agaçante on
adore ça qu'on est des gens avec des
couteaux qui sont ma nation et qui nous
est au dessus oui j'irai pas camper un
endroit où il ya personne c'est mort il
est temps de passer à la deuxième
histoire c'est celle de maya maya son
histoire elle est très récente
puisqu'elle est arrivé pendant le
confinement pendant les confinements
n'avait le droit de sortir pour faire de
l'activité physique et c'est ce que
marié a décidé de faire parce qu'à force
de rester chez elle toute la journée
elle avait besoin de se dépenser ce jour
là elle va donc courir comme
régulièrement dans le parc à côté de
chez elles sauf que comme l a pas
beaucoup de cardio elle explique qu'elle
est systématiquement obligé de faire une
petite pause
ce jour là pendant sa pause elle regarde
autour d'elle comme d'habitude et elle
croise le regard de quelqu'un qui la
fixe ça arrive de croiser le regard de
quelqu'un elle n'est pas affoler plus
que ça et après un petit moment elle
reprend son jogging
mais quand elle reprend son jogging elle
voit au loin que cet inconnu se met à
marcher et il se met à marcher dans la
même direction qu'elle
après plusieurs minutes elle regarde
autour d'elle et elle comprend que
heureusement elle a réussi à le semer
sauf que maya elle a tort il est 22h
mayenne retour chez elle elle sort de la
douche elle décide d'aller se coucher et
à travers la fenêtre de sa chambre elle
remarque des phares de voiture qui
tourne dans sa rue maya elle vit dans
une rue très calme quand une voiture
passe dans cette rue c'est 95% du temps
un habitant qui rentre chez lui sauf que
ce jour là la voiture que maya aperçoit
elle fait des va et vient dans la rue
c'est donc parfaitement inhabituel après
plusieurs va-et-vient la voiture
s'arrête
devant la maison de miles et un homme
côté passager en descend il ya donc
quelqu'un qui conduit et ils sont deux
et sept hommes qui descend de la voiture
vous en doutez c'est l'homme qu'elle a
aperçu plutôt dans le parc
maya assiste à ça en regardant à travers
la fenêtre de sa chambre et d'un coup
l'inconnu lève les yeux vers la fenêtre
de la chambre de maya et croise son
regard
maya elle se dit tout de suite que le
mec est un stalker relou qui vient
toquer pour la braguette
elle décide de fermer ces stores et elle
va dormir c'est chelou jamais je vais
dormir comment tu fais ma ya pourtant
bat les couilles comme ça c'est
incroyable
et évidemment elle est réveillée un peu
plus tard par un tapotement sur sa
fenêtre
ah bon elle ouvre les yeux et on y
distingue la silhouette d'un homme
probablement le même puisqu'elle voit en
contrebas les phares de la voiture de
tout à l'heure à la elle se dit mais
comment il a fait ma chandelle au
deuxième étage il a escaladé le toit du
rez-de-chaussée pour atteindre la
fenêtre de ma chambre c'est pas des
manières ça c'est quand même étrange
après quelques minutes à faire semblant
de dormir en restant immobile dans son
lit elle se lève
elle prend son téléphone elle appelle la
police l'opérateur lui dis ok
effectivement ce n'est pas normal
ne bougez pas une patrouille est en
route et elle arrive dans cinq minutes
après plusieurs minutes maya elle entend
un gros bruit sourd elle en conclut que
c'est probablement le bruit qui a fait
l'inconnu en sautant de son toit et puis
d'un coup sa toque à la porte
au rez-de-chaussée cette fois et après
que c est ok une voix rassurante dit
c'est la police vous nous avez appelé
ouvrait maillard descend en rez de
chaussée elle s'apprête à ouvrir la
porte mais avant d'ouvrir la porte
elle veut remercier et dire au revoir à
l'opératrice qu'elle a toujours au bout
du fil elle a remercié lui dit que la
patrouille est là elle s'apprête à
raccrocher mais au moment de raccrocher
l'opératrice lui dit attendez la
patrouille est toujours en route
là ce que vous venez d'entendre c'est
pas la police donc nous vrai surtout pas
maya sur la pointe des pieds remonte au
1er étage et là elle va attendre de
longues minutes avant que la police
arrive et que cette fois les vrais
policiers frappent à sa porte en disant
ouvrés c'est la police vous nous avez
appelé cette fois l'opératrice lui dit
c'est bon c'est bien la patrouille
cette fois maya ou la porte et ja devant
chez elle trois voitures de police et
environ six policiers qui lui demandent
ce qui vient de se passer et comment ils
peuvent l'aider elle raconte tout
évidemment les deux mecs s'était déjà
barré et dans ces cas là bas la police
elle peut rien faire à part faire des
patrouilles les jours qui suivent pour
intervenir si jamais les ravisseurs
décide de revenir mais généralement
c'est pas le cas
moi je vais vous dire un truc quand sa
toque même si j'attends quelqu'un à une
heure précise que sa toque à cette heure
précise je regarde toujours dans l'oeil
de ma porte je sais pas pourquoi j'ai
trop peur qu'il ya des gens qui sonne et
qu'ils soient mal intentionnés ces
terribles des fois même si des livreurs
et je reste dix secondes comme ça à être
sûr que
on sait jamais messieurs dames c'est
l'heure de la troisième histoire c'est
celle de simon et je les aime beaucoup
parce que c'est des jeunes qui sont fans
d' aventure frissonnante comme nous sauf
qu'ils ont vécu des trucs que ne veut
pas vivre à cette époque simon à 19 ans
il est dans la fleur de l'âge qui bosse
chez mcdo et un vendredi après le
travail
il rejoint des amis à lui et comme ils
sont tous un peu femme d'histoires
d'horreur il décide de se rendre à un
endroit connu pour être hantée dans la
région weitz bridge
la légende raconte que dans les années
1920 fermier local aurait pété un câble
après avoir appris que sa femme le
trompait et l'aurait tuée elle et son
amant après avoir commis cet acte
impardonnable
il se serait rendu sur ce point sur
lequel il aurait après une prise de
conscience soudaine décidé de se pendre
simon explique que bien évidemment cette
histoire est absolument fausse mais qu'à
l'époque il avait 19 ans il était fan
d'histoires d'horreur et il croyait à
mort et ils prennent la route en
direction du pont évidemment puis se
rapproche de ce pont plus est paumé et
moins ils ont deux réseaux on en 2006 et
c'est vrai que le réseau il n'était pas
aussi bien que maintenant bref un
dernier virage et nos amis tombent sur
the whites bridge effectivement on dirai
clairement le pont d'un film d'horreur
il est vieux il est usé il fait badea
l'entrée du pont et tombe directement
sur un épouvantail dans cette bande de
potes
il ya un mec qui s'appelle max est un
peu le casse cou c'est un peu le fait
les du groupe et mikey fait une
dinguerie il prend l'épouvantail et il
allume avec son briquet évidemment ça
prend feu directs alors oui c'est une
vraie idée de merde vu qu'ils sont sur
un pont en bois qu'en plus il n'a pas
plu depuis un moment et que le bois est
parfaitement sec
heureusement après plusieurs secondes
mike se rend compte et jette
l'épouvantail enflammé dans la rivière
et s'assure qu'ils aient pas de bresse
qui traînent sur le pont l'exploration
du pont touche à sa fin c'est un petit
pont c'est pas un truc de dingue mais
bon nos amis n'ont pas assez frissonner
et brandon leur dit écoutez les gars
la légende raconte que si on garde notre
voiture au milieu du pont qu'on la met
au point mort et qu'on coupe le moteur
l'esprit du fermier mort poule sera la
voiture vers l'avant pour le faire
sortir du pont c'est complètement con on
est d'accord c'est complètement con mais
vendredi soir jeunesse fans de légendes
qui font peur let's go il remonte donc
dans la voiture ils vont sur le pont y
met le point mort et coupe le contact et
là il se retrouve assis dans le noir
absolu dans le silence absolu à attendre
qu'il se passe un truc il ya juste des
bruits du bon qui
des bruits de rivière qui coule sous le
pont et d'un coup des bruits de pas et
ils ont même pas le temps de réaliser
que c'est vraiment des bruits de pas la
portière arrière gauche de la voiture
s'ouvre et une femme entre et s'assoit
dans la voiture et un petit silence nos
amis regardent cette femme et cette
femme leur dit qu'elle est vraiment
contente qu'il soit là parce que la
voiture de son petit ami est tombé en
panne et qu'elle a besoin qu'on la
ramène chez elle
quentin et ses potes se regardent
comprennent toujours pas ce qui se passe
et ils lui disent désolés mais déjà vous
êtes qui et qu'est ce que vous foutez là
et là le ton de la femme change
elle se met à leur répondent très
sèchement elle leur dit froidement
écoutez je viens de vous expliquer est
ce que s'il vous plaît vous pouvez me
conduire jusqu'à chez moi pour pas que
j'ai à faire le trajet à pied quentin
qui conduit la voiture croiser le regard
de la femme dans le rétroviseur et il se
dit il ya un blême et décide de dire à
la femme de descendre de la voiture et
de dégager la femme soupire ouvre la
portière et retournant marcheurs de là
d'où elle vient c'est à dire l'obscurité
quant à et ses potes se regardent ils se
disent ils c'est vraiment pressé un truc
la voiture est toujours au milieu du
pont et face à eux il ya juste l'espace
pour faire demi tour et aussi un petit
chemin qui part sur la droite et qui a
l'air de mener nulle part ils avancent
donc dans l'espace pour faire demi tour
et en regardant sur leur droite et voit
effectivement grâce aux phares de la
voiture au loin une voiture qu'à l'ère
des temps pam
et là évidemment ils se sentent bien
court puisque la meuf ils l'ont bien
envoyer chier et c'est là que mike leur
fait remarquer un truc la voiture au
loin elle est dans un bien trop sale
état pour être simplement en panne
s'était bien du bullshit ce que cette
femme vient nous raconter mais alors
elle voulait quoi quand on ne veut pas
savoir il retraverse le pont et il se
casse à ce jour ils sont jamais
retournés ils ont eu des frissons qui
cherchait du coup c'est bien il pense
qu'elle était probablement complice d'un
futur guet-apens qu'elles voulaient les
emmener à un endroit en son genre que
c'était chez elles sauf que c'était pas
chez elle et qu en arrivant sur place et
elle se faire voler la voiture ou pierre
on n'en sait rien en tout cas il ya
plein d'histoires qui ont continué à
circuler à propos de ce pont c'était
vraiment une légende locale et
apparemment il ya des jeunes qui il ya
quelques années et ont foutu le feu ce
qui a mis fin à toutes les légendes d'un
coup lui et ses amis en tout cas ont
décidé de ne plus jamais y retourner
parce qu'ils ont vraiment eu peur ce
soir-là et car ils ont de la chance
bref j'espère que ça vous a plu j'ai
envie de mater un film d'horreur je vais
pas privé mais sait-on jamais si vous
avez des petites pépites a recommandé je
suis méga show comme d'hab j'aime bien
vous souhaiter bonne nuit après ça et
regardez pas votre finale c'est une
voiture fait des va-et-vient on sait
jamais allez bisous
[Musique]